The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
In That case, let's get started.
First with our review of what
we talked about last time.
We began by talking
about the dynamics
of a flat radiation-dominated
universe, which
is very straightforward.
We start with Friedmann's
equation for a flat universe.
For radiation, rho is
proportional to one over a
to the fourth.
So that gets us a
dot over a squared
is equal to a constant
over a to the fourth.
Rearranging that we can
write it as a times da
is equal to the square root
of that constant times dt.
And then we can just
integrate both sides.
So you get one half a squared
is equal to the square root
of the constant times t, plus
a new constant, constant prime.
OK, then we say that we can
adjust this constant prime
by resetting our clocks.
And we haven't said
anything yet that determines
how our clocks are set.
So the standard convention
is to set your clocks
so that t equals 0 is the time
when the scale factor is zero.
And that corresponds to
constant prime equals zero,
as one can see by just
looking at that equation.
So that's what we do when the
constant prime term disappears.
And then we don't care about
the constant of proportionality
anyway.
For a flat universe the
constant of proportionality
is completely meaningless.
It just tells you how
many meters per notch
you're dealing with, so
it defines your notch,
but otherwise has no
physical meaning whatever.
So the important bottom
line is that a of t
is proportional to
the square root of t
for a flat [INAUDIBLE]
dominated universe.
And once one knows
that, one can easily
get quite a few other things.
OK.
As I was just saying, once
you now how a of t behaves
you can immediately calculate
lots of other things.
And in particular h is a dot
over a and that is just 1
over 2t.
So we know what h is,
a function of time,
even without putting
any more details
about what kind of
radiation we have.
It doesn't matter.
You still get h is
equal to 1 over 2t.
The horizon distance is given
by the formula a of t times
the integral from 0
to t of c over a of t
prime, dt prime, the
interval represents
the total co-moving
distance that light
could travel between
time 0 at time t.
And then one multiplies
that by the scale
factor time t to turn it
into a physical distance,
and that then becomes the
horizon distance of time t.
And that is two times ct.
You might remember
it was three times
ct for the
matter-dominated case.
And then finally you
even know exactly what
the mass density is
as a function of time.
Because 8 squared is 8 pi over
3 rho a pi g over 3 times rho.
And we know what h is.
So that tells me
what row is also.
We actually know the mass
density as a function of time,
independent of anything else.
OK.
Then we began talking about
black-body radiation, which
is basically a gas of massless
particles at a temperature t
that is a gas of
massless particles
in thermal equilibrium.
And it turns out that
the temperature t
determines almost everything.
So the energy density of
black-body radiation, u,
which is the same as rho
mass density times c squared,
is equal to a kind of a
fudge factor g times pi
squared over 30 times kt to
the fourth, over h bar c cubed.
And this fudge factor g
is equal to 2 for photons.
And the reason we gave it a
letter instead of just writing
a two in the formula
in the first place
is that we'll soon be talking
about black-body radiation
of other kinds of
particles, and g
will be different for
different kinds of particles.
The two for photons
is given the number
two because there are two
spin states of photons.
Photons that are massless
spin one particle and massless
particles, all we have maximum
spins, they don't have spins
in the middle, so they spin
along one axis for a photon
is either plus or minus
1, which is two spins.
That's the quantum
mechanical description.
It corresponds completely
to the classical description
that you can separate
any light wave
into left-circularly polarized
and a right-circularly
polarized part.
Or equivalently, you could
separate it into an x-polarized
and and y-polarized part.
And you can get x-polarization
by superimposing
left and right, so these are
not alternative polarizations.
They're just two different
ways of describing
the general polarization.
The general causation
is a linear combination
of either left and right or
linear combination of x and y.
In any case, the basis
has two basis elements,
and that's where
the two comes from.
Next item on our
list is the pressure
which could be calculated from
the statistical mechanics,
and we've already
calculated by other means.
But the answer, not
matter how you calculate
is is p equals 1/3 u.
Next we talked about
the number density.
And these are all calculations
that we didn't really do.
I'm just quoting
standard calculations
from statistical mechanics.
And you can learn how
to do them presumably
by some [INAUDIBLE] class.
The number density is
a different constant g
star, in general it's different.
For photons it ends
up being the same.
But in general a
different constant,
g star times zeta
of 3 where zeta of 3
is the Riemann zeta function
evaluated at argument three.
And that's equal to 1 over
1 cubed plus 1 over 2 cubed,
plus 1 over 3 cubed dot dot dot.
And it adds up to 1.202
to three decimal places.
And then the rest divided by
pi squared then times kt cubed,
over h bar c cubed.
So the number [INAUDIBLE] like
the cube of the temperature,
while the energy density
went like the fourth power
of the temperature.
And the g star that appears here
as I mentioned already I think
is 2 for photons.
And we'll learn
more later about how
to apply this to other
kinds of particles.
And finally the entropy
density is the same g
as we had for energy densities
times 2 pi squared over 45 k
to the fourth t
cubed, again it goes
like t cubed, divided
by h bar c cubed.
And entropy is a
somewhat subtle concept.
Fortunately for our
purposes we will not
need to know much at all about
what entropy actually is.
I might just say for some sense
of completeness that entropy
is a measure of quote
the disorder of a state.
And this "disorder"
means some measure
of the number of different
microscopic quantum states
that contribute to a given
macroscopic classical
description.
The important thing for
us is, well first of all,
that the second law
of thermodynamics
tells us that entropy
never decreases,
but we're going to make use of
a much stronger statement which
holds very well for the
early universe, which
is that if the system stays
close to family equilibrium,
then the entropy doesn't change.
And in the early universe
I think for every process
that we're going to discuss
that condition holds.
The system stays close to
thermal equilibrium and entropy
is conserved.
The one exception
will be inflation,
which we'll learn about
near the end of the course.
At the end of inflation there's
a humongously entropy producing
phase transition.
And if inflation is right
essentially all of the entropy
that we have int
he universe today
was produced during
that phase transition.
Before that there was
only negligible entropy.
OK.
That's it for my summary.
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I know it's a law
that entropy only increases.
Is there anything
behind that or is it
just it's a law of physics?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
a subtle question,
which I think if you ask 10
different physicists you'll
likely get 10 different answers.
But one thing's for
sure is that it does not
follow as a consequence from
the other laws of physics
that we know.
The other laws of
physics that we know
are essentially time,
reversal, and variant.
So why entropy always increases
is something of a mystery.
The usual story is something
like the early universe,
for reasons unknown, started
in the state of peculiarly
low entropy.
And because it started low it's
approaching the equilibrium
value, which is much larger.
So that's a possible
explanation.
I actually am in the
process of writing
a paper about the growth of
entropy in the hour of time,
and maybe I'll get
a chance to tell you
about that sometime before
the end of the course,
but I won't try
to explain it now.
But it's a slightly
different idea
about what could explain it.
But it's something of a mystery.
Nobody really knows what
determines the arrow of time,
why entropy only goes one way.
Any other questions?
OK.
What I want to do
now is to continue
talking about
black-body radiation.
I think we've said
everything that we wanted
to say about photons,
but now we want
to apply to other
kinds of particles.
And we're going to begin with
neutrinos, because neutrinos
certainly do account for
a significant fraction
of the entropy in the
universe today even.
Neutrinos were, until
around 1990 or so,
thought to be massless.
Now we know that they in
fact have a small mass.
I think I mentioned last
time that we have never
measured the mass of a neutrino
and largely for that reason,
we don't actually know
what the masses are.
But what we have
measured is something
that's quantum mechanical
and rather peculiar, which
is that one type of
neutrino, and neutrinos
come in three types, or flavors.
And that is nu sub e, nu
sub mu, and nu sub tau.
And what we've seen is that
neutrinos of one flavor
can turn into, just by
traveling through space,
a neutrino of the other flavor.
And that can only happen
if there's a non-zero mass.
And what it
particular measures is
delta m squared
between the neutrinos.
And I think I even
wrote on the formulas
on the blackboard for
the known limits of that.
So I won't write it again.
But neutrino
oscillation, which is
what we call this,
the conversion of one
kind of neutrino
to another, implies
that delta m squared
is not equal to zero.
So it's still, in
principle, possible
that one of these neutrinos
could be massless,
but they can't all be massless.
If one is massless, the
other two have mass.
And of delta m
squared is very small.
So these would be smaller
masses than any other particles
that we know of in the universe.
Now for purposes of
cosmology it turns out
that you can get by by
thinking of the neutrinos
as being massless.
And then we'll start by
discussing it that way.
It's not quite as
trivial as just
saying that the mass
is a small number.
So if you have a formula
that involves the mass,
you can usually neglect it.
It's a little bit more subtle
because whether the neutrinos
are massless or massive affects
the number of spin states.
And we're going to even treat
the number of spin states
as if the neutrino is
massless, which obviously
is a bit of a cheat and
needs further explanation.
But I'm going to do it
first for massless neutrinos
and we'll come back
later to discuss
why you can get the same answers
if the neutrino has a mass.
So we're going to
start out imagining
that the nu's are massless.
And in that approximation
there is only
one spin state for a neutrino
and it's left-handed.
And that means that the spin
points the opposite direction
from the momentum.
So if the neutrino is
spinning like this,
which my right hand
will correspond
to a spin in that
direction, the momentum
will always be in
that direction.
And I can do the
same thing this way.
If it's spinning like
this, the spin is that way,
the momentum would be that way.
The momentum's always the
opposite direction of the spin.
Now you might
realize and that that
leads to a question
about Lorentz invariance.
If the spin and the momentum
point in opposite directions
in some frame, it's not
obvious if they would also
point in opposite directions
in some other frame.
But it turns out to be true.
One can verify that, which
we're not going to do,
but it is a Lorentz
invariance statement,
as long as the
particle's massless.
If the particle's
not massless it
is clearly not a Lorentz
invariance statement.
And that's easy to say.
If the particle were
not massless, and say
it was spinning this way,
so the spin is that way,
and the momentum is
that way, that way
the situation and the
particle had a mass,
then I could change Lorentz
frames by jumping into a rocket
ship, and shooting
off in this direction,
the same direction the
particle is moving,
and since the particle is moving
with some finite velocity,
if it has a mass, there has
to be a finite velocity,
in principle the
spaceship can overtake it.
And when the spaceship
overtakes it,
from the point of
view of the spaceship,
the momentum will now
be pointing that way,
but the spin doesn't change
when the spaceship overtakes it.
So this relationship
between spin and momentum
is manifestly not
Lorentz invariant
when the particle
has a mass, which
is why we are cheating
in a somewhat big way
here, by saying that
we're going to treat
the neutrinos is massless.
We're going to even
be ignoring this fact
that what we're saying
about the spin and momentum
is not even Lorentz invariant
if the particle has a mass.
And we'll make better
excuses for that later,
but for now we'll see simple
picture first, and then
talk about the more
complicated picture later.
Anti neutrinos, which I'll
write with a bar over it,
also have one spin state.
And as you might guess
since anti particles are
kind of the opposite
of particles,
that is right-handed.
Now in addition neutrinos differ
from photons in that neutrinos
belong to a class of
particles called fermions.
Photons are bosons.
How many of you already
know about [INAUDIBLE]
fermion or boson?
OK.
Most, but not quite all.
Fair enough.
So fermions are particles
that obey the Fermi exclusion
principle that
you're very likely
learned about in a
chemistry class someplace.
It says that no
two particles can
be in exactly the
same quantum state.
Bosons do not obey
such a principle.
In fact, bosons are
even more likely to be
found in the same quantum state.
And that's the
important difference.
In quantum field theory, and
only in quantum field theory,
you can't do this in just non
relativistic quantum mechanics,
but in quantum field theory
you can prove something called
the spin statistics
theorem, which
says that particles with half
integer spins, that is 1/2,
3/2, et cetera, are
necessarily fermions.
And particles with integer
spins are necessarily bosons.
So we know whether a particle
is a fermion or a Boson
as soon as we know its spin.
And in the case of
neutrino, it's spin 1/2.
So nu's have spin one half.
And that makes them fermions.
Now the statistical mechanics
formulas that we just went over
come about from counting states.
Basically the
underlying principle
is that the system is
likely to be in any state
that you could imagine with the
probability of e to the minus
the energy of that
state, divided by kt
all in the exponent.
So it's state counting that
determines these formulas.
And that means it's going
to be different for fermions
and bosons because
for bosons you're
going to count situations
where there are
many particles in
the same state.
And for fermions you're not.
And in particular
that means you're
going to be counting more
states for the bosons
and to be counting fewer
states for the fermions.
So you would expect these
constants g and g star
to be smaller for fermions
than they are for those bosons.
And that indeed is true.
So for fermions g
gets an extra factor
that is multiplied by 7/8s.
And g star is multiplied by 3/4.
So I think we could have
predicted that these g's would
get factors that
are less than 1,
simply because we're
counting fewer states.
I think we can also predict
without doing any calculations
that g should have a
bigger factor than g star.
Remember g star
is the factor that
appears in the number density.
So if we want to calculate the
average energy per particle
at a given temperature,
we would take
a formula which has a g in
it for the energy density,
and divide it by
a formula that has
a g star in it for
the number density.
The energy density divided
by the number density
is just the energy per particle.
And this tells us that
we'll get a number that's
bigger than 1 for the fermions.
So for fermions,
there's slightly
more energy per particle
than there is for bosons.
And I think that's easily
believable because fermions
obey this exclusion principle.
It means once you put one
particle in the lowest energy
state, you can't
put any more there.
You have to put them in
higher energy states.
So the expectation
would be that you
have more energy per
particle with the fermions
and that is indeed what
the [INAUDIBLE] calculation
indicates.
So now we're ready to
write down a formula for g,
for the neutrinos.
And this will be
the overall g that
occurs in the formula
for the energy
density and the entropy density,
and the pressure for neutrinos.
And it will, we'll write it
out as a string of factors.
We'll first of all have this
factor 7/8 coming from the fact
that they're fermions.
Then we'll have
a factor of three
because there are three flavors.
And we're just going to
add them together here.
So we get a factor of three.
Then we get a factor
of two because there's
particle anti particle pairs.
That is, we have to count
both neutrinos and anti
neutrinos, and the
total energy density.
For photons, a photon is
the same as an anti photon,
so you don't get an
extra particle connected
with the anti particle.
But for neutrinos you
do, so that gives you
a factor of two here.
And then you always have
the number of spin states,
but in this case, the of
number spin state is one,
but I'll write it
just so we can keep
track of the general pattern.
And when you do that
multiplication, you get 21/4.
So g sub nu for all three
neutrinos put together is 21/4.
And you could put this
into all of our formulas
and get the energy
density pressure,
and entropy density
for neutrinos.
Then we're also interested
in g star, which
will give us the number density.
So g star sub nu.
And it differs only
by the first factor.
3/4 for the fermion
nature of the particle.
And the rest is just dittos.
And what you get
in the end is 9/2.
OK, now this does not
end our discussion
of black-body radiation
in the early universe
Because as we go back
in time to earlier times
we can come to a times when
KT, the main thermal energy,
is large compared to the
rest energy of an electron,
m sub e c squared.
So at these very high
temperatures even
e plus, e minus pairs contribute
to the black-body radiation.
So we'd like to write down a
g four e plus, e minus pairs.
Actually, maybe I shouldn't call
them pairs because they really
are contributing individually,
but g for e plus, e minus.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I know
said that we're
assuming, even though it's
a spin 1/2 particle that's
just one spin state.
I was wondering is it possible
for a spin 1/2 particle
to be massless?
I can't think of any
offhand, because don't they
have to have m equals negative
1/2 state? [INAUDIBLE]
in general.
PROFESSOR: Right.
No, it is perfectly
consistent, would
be perfectly consistent for
neutrinos to be massless.
And then they would only
have and m equals 1/2 state
in spite of the fact
that their spin 1/2.
And the m equals minus 1/2
state would just be missing,
but that's OK.
It's similar to what
happens with photons.
Photons are spin one particles.
And the m equals 0
state is missing.
And that can only happen
with massless particles.
For massive particles,
by basically the argument
that I gave about catching
up to the neutrino,
it's not possible
to have one helicity
and not have the other.
But for massless
particles it is possible.
The photon does it.
We used to think
the neutrino did it.
Turned up the neutrino
doesn't do it,
but we can still describe
the old theory, which
is simpler than the new theory.
And that's what I'm doing.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
reason they're missing those?
PROFESSOR: OK.
The question is is
there any reason
why they're missing
those spin states.
The answer basically is that
there's no solid reason, which
is why we didn't know if it was
going to be missing the states
or not.
But for the case of
massless particles
only the m states
are all completely
disconnected from each other
under Lorentz transformations.
For any non-zero mass,
all the spin states mix.
And because they all mix
under Lorentz transformations
you can't have any one
without having all of them.
But that statement
disappears when
the particle becomes massless.
So when the particle
becomes massless,
essentially, each spin state
is its own kind of particle.
And it might be part of a
spectrum of real particles,
or might not.
And we don't know any
fundamental principle
that answers that question,
other than experiment.
OK.
So I was just
going to write down
a g for e plus, e minus pairs.
Remember this g determines the
energy density, the pressure,
and the entropy density.
And it again has a factor of
7/8 because these are fermions.
It has a factor of one to sort
of follow the general pattern
because there's only one
species of electrons.
For neutrinos we had three, but
for electrons we just have one.
We do get a factor
of two for particles,
anti particles because an e plus
is different from an e minus.
And there are two spin
states for the electron.
If could be spin up, or spin
down, or spin equals 1/2,
and there's spin
equals minus 1/2.
So there are two spin states.
And that gives us a
factor of 7/2 for g.
And for g star e plus, e minus,
the only difference again,
is in the first factor, which
is 3/4 for fermions for g star.
And then times dot, dot, dot.
And that then is equal to just
a nice round factor of three.
And then if we go back
to this earlier time,
we have not only the
e plus, e minus pairs,
which started to exist when
we crossed this threshold,
we also have photons
and neutrinos.
So for kt, large
compared to m sub ec
squared, and I should say small
compared to the next threshold,
m sub nu c squared,
mass of a muon.
The mass of the muon as
106 MeV Mass of electron
is a half of an MeV.
So there's are good
long range here where
this is the right number.
So g total is equal to
2 plus 21/4 plus 7/2
equals 10 and 3/4.
So this number 10 and 3/4
plays an important role
in a long segment of the
history of our universe.
Another number that you
might be interested in
is the energy density of
radiation in the universe
today.
And the e plus, e minus
pairs are of course
long since frozen out because
kt is a lot less than half
of an MeV.
So we just have
neutrinos and photons.
You might think
that we could just
add the formulas for photons
to the formula for neutrinos,
but that turns out
not to be right.
And the reason
it's not right now
is that we believe that the
temperature of the neutrinos
is not the same as the
temperature of the photons.
And this is a
problem that you'll
be working out on the
next homework set,
so I won't give all
the details here
because I want you to have
the fun of working out
those details.
But I'll tell you the
outline of what it is.
The transition occurs
when kt crosses
this magic threshold
of m sub e c
squared, which means that the
electron positron pairs are
going to start to disappear from
the thermal equilibrium mix.
Now those electron
positron pairs
have both energy and entropy.
It turns out that the energy
is very hard to keep track of.
And the reason why
that is true is
that we know that du dt is equal
to minus 3h, times rho plus p,
I think i have this right.
times u.
No, not times u.
And this might be a u.
Yeah, I think this is right.
But what is definitely
true is that it involves
the pressure as well
as the energy density.
And keeping track of
what the pressure's
doing as a function
of time is complicated
because depending on exactly
what the mix of particles
are and the pressure
is even given
by a more complicated
formula when you're
very near the
threshold, that is when
kt is near the
mass of a particle,
there's a more complicated
formula for the pressure.
So the pressure is
hard to keep track of.
But the entropy turns out
to be easy to keep track
of because entropy is simply
conserved during this process.
So on the problem that you'll be
doing for the next problem set
you'll be looking at the entropy
contained in these e plus
e minus pairs.
And then there's an important
assumption which is valid.
We will not really
try to justify it,
but at the time when the e
plus, e minus pairs go out
of equilibrium,
when they disappear
from the thermal equilibrium
mix as kt falls below m sub
ec squared, at that point the
photons are still interacting
strongly with everything
else, and with each other.
But the neutrinos have
pretty much decoupled.
They're not really interacting
with anything anymore.
So when the e
plus, e minus pairs
disappear they give
essentially all
of their entropy to the
photons, and essentially not
of their entropy
to the neutrinos.
And that means that
you can calculate
the entropy density
of the photons,
and the entropy density
of the neutrinos
and you can calculate from
that the relative temperatures
between the two.
And the net effect is
that the photons end up
with a higher temperature
than the neutrinos.
So cosmology makes a
clear prediction here.
The universe today
should be bathed
in a thermal distribution
of neutrinos.
The temperature I think ends up
being about 2.4 degrees Kelvin,
a little colder
than the photons.
And it's really
the great challenge
of observational
cosmology to try
to measure those
thermal neutrinos.
Because neutrinos
interact so weakly,
nobody has come
close to measuring
the existence of
those neutrinos.
Everybody thinks
they must be there,
if anybody's discovers
they're not there,
it'll be a major shift in our
understanding of cosmology.
But nobody really knows
how to measure them.
So you guys could try
to do that sometime
during your career
as physicists.
So putting these things
together what you'll show
is that the temperature
of neutrinos
should be equal
to 4/11 to the 1/3
power times the
temperature of the photons.
And given that,
we can write down
a formula for the energy
density in radiation today.
So u [? rad ?] 0 for today
is equal to g for photons,
plus 21/4, which is
g for the neutrinos,
but then we have to
correct for the fact
that the neutrinos are
at the lower temperature,
and remember energy density's
go like the fourth power
of the temperature.
So there's a
correction here, which
is the fourth
power of this 4/11.
So this multiplies
4/11 to the 4/3 power,
the fourth power
of the temperature.
And then the rest of the
formula for energy density.
Pi squared over 30 times
k, times the temperature
of the photons to the fourth
power, divided by h bar
c cubed.
And if you plug
numbers into this,
you get a number which I
wrote on the blackboard
when we started talking about
radiation for the radiation
density of today's universe.
It's 7.01 times 10 to the minus
14 jewels per meter cubed.
So now we know how to derive
this formula that I pulled out
out of hat when we first started
talking about energy density
radiation.
You might remember we
used this to calculate
when radiation matter
equality took place.
OK.
Any questions about this?
Well in that case now I'm
ready to come back and talk
about neutrino masses
more realistically.
OK. [INAUDIBLE] the
mass we now know.
Or at least two out
of the three do.
And still I argued, or
told you, that the mass
didn't matter for the
calculations we just did.
And that seems a little
strange because the calculation
we just did depended on counting
the numbers of spin states,
and the number of spin
states, of course,
changes if the
particles have a mass.
Neutrinos could not
have just one spin state
if they had a mass.
So the question
then is what happens
to these right-handed neutrinos.
Remember the neutrinos we
know and love are left-handed.
OK.
Nobody has ever seen a
right-handed neutrino.
But if the neutrino has
a mass, they must exist.
And one way to see
is that argument
I gave you about catching
up to the neutrino
and going faster than it.
And then a left-hand
neutrino would
turn into a right-handed
neutrino, which
is, this is all you
did, was change frames,
and the world is
Lorentz invariant.
It means that right-handed
neutrinos must in principle
exist in any frame.
OK.
It turns out that
there are two theories
of how the neutrino mass works.
And we don't know yet which
of these theories is correct.
And they are called the
possibility of a Dirac mass
or the possibility
of a Majorana mass.
And these are both
named after people,
so don't try to parse anything
about the physical meaning
of those words from the name.
The Dirac mass is
the easier one for us
to understand because
it's the same kind of mass
that an electron has.
So if the neutrinos
have a Dirac mass
it really would mean that there
are right-handed neutrinos,
which are a new
species a particle
that we haven't
seen yet, but which
would be implied by the
existence of this mass.
The catch is that because
of the very peculiar way
that the neutrinos
interact it is
possible for the
right-handed neutrinos
to interact vastly more weakly
than the left handed neutrinos.
And that would be
the explanation
for why we've never seen
them because they interact
so extraordinarily weakly.
And even in the early universe
where everything almost reaches
thermal equilibrium,
the cross-section
for producing
right-handed neutrinos
would be so small that they
would essentially never
be produced.
So right-handed nu's
interact so weakly
that they're not seen in
lab, or in early universe.
OK.
The other type is more peculiar.
And there are no other
particles in nature
that are known to have
this type of mass,
but it's a theoretical
possibility.
Majorana masses can
only be possessed
by particles which are neutral,
but neutrinos are neutral.
And if neutrinos
have a Majorana mass
it would mean that the
right-handed partner
of the left handed
neutrinos that we see
would in fact be a particle
that we already know about,
but it will be the particle
that we have previously
identified as the
right-handed anti neutrino.
So if the Majorana
hypothesis is true,
the anti neutrino
and the neutrino
would be the same particle.
And one would be the
right-handed version
and the other would be
the left-handed version.
And that is also a
possibility, we just know know.
And in this case,
clearly what we
said about the
early universe still
works because we did
the counting right.
If it's the direct
possibility we
would have to do a
further argument,
we justify the fact that these
right-handed partners interact
so weakly that we would
never see them even
in the early universe,
but that is the case.
And for the Majorana
case there clearly
is no real difference from
the calculations that we did.
Any questions about that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What
exactly do you mean
when you say the direct
mass is like the electrons?
PROFESSOR: Right.
What I mean is that it appears
in the equations of motion
in the same way that the that
the electron mass appears,
and therefore like the electron
there's a right-handed electron
and there's also a left-handed
handed electron, which are just
related to each other by
a parity transformation.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is it not a problem
in the Majorana case [INAUDIBLE]
particle?
Doesn't there have
to be an [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
The question is
doesn't there have
to be an anti particle,
how can the neutrino
and the anti neutrino
be the same particle.
The answer is no.
The photon does not
have an anti particle.
So particles that have
a charge of any kind
must have an anti particle,
but if the particle is really
neutral then it can just
be it's own anti particle,
and that would be the case here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I
have two questions.
One is what is the
difference between a neutrino
and a anti neutrino besides?
I mean, how do we know
they're the same, that they
are the same
particle [INAUDIBLE].
It's not just a
matter of semantics.
If the only difference that
we can see is [INAUDIBLE].
Whether we call it
the anti neutrino
or say that it's the same
particle, just [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK.
You're saying how do we know
whether the anti neutrino was
the same particle
as the neutrino,
and what do we mean by
that statement anyway.
I guess the answer is really
something that comes out
of the fundamental equations
in the context of the quantum
field theory.
But maybe I can say something
more concrete, however.
There's a quantum number
called Lepton number,
and actually divides into
three kinds of quantum numbers,
so there's an electron number,
muon number, and a tau number.
And for all the
interactions that we've
seen that number is
conserved, that is
the sum of the
number of electrons
minus the number
of anti electrons,
plus the number of
electron neutrinos,
minus the number of
anti electron neutrinos
is conserved.
And if that were a rigorous
conservation law, then
it would really mean that
the neutrino was not neutral.
It would have this
nonzero charge
called electron charge
for the electron neutrino.
So the Majorana
possibility requires
that that quantity is
not really conserved.
So that's an important
fact about nature
that we haven't really
learned yet, whether or not
it's exactly conserved or only
highly approximately conserved.
The belief is that it's only
highly approximately conserved,
but we don't know.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does a
neutrino [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You are right.
You're very quick.
You are right that neutrino
oscillations are certainly
enough to prove that the
individual Lepton numbers are
not conserved, but they
still have the possibility
that total Lepton
number can be conserved,
which we don't
think is true, but I
don't think we've ruled
it out yet either.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In the Majorana case,
if they are the same particle,
do they still come in left
and right-handed forms
so as to keep the
[INAUDIBLE] the same value,
or do they only come in
the left-handed phase,
in which case the [INAUDIBLE]
would be decreased [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well,
the counting that we
had before would be correct.
And the only question is
whether the factor of two
that we put here for
particle, anti particle
is here where maybe the
particle's really neutral
and the factor of two is
the number of spin states,
but it's the same
result either way.
It's all in the
question of whether
the left-handed neutrino
is the anti particle
or the right-handed
neutrino, or another spin
state of the right-handed.
I'm sorry.
I'm saying this wrong.
The question is whether
the right-handed neutrino
is the anti particle of
the left-handed neutrino
or whether it's
another spin states
of the left-handed neutrino.
But either way the number
particles that we think exists
would be the same in the
mayorana description.
OK?
OK.
Now we're ready to
actually write down
for example a formula for kt.
So sticking to this time range
of kt is much, much bigger
than m sub eb squared,
but kt is much, much less
than m sub nu c squared.
We can write down a
formula-- I'm sorry.
Actually the formula's
more general.
I didn't really look
carefully what I wrote.
Forget this.
As long as we know what little
g is, and this formula's going
to have a little
g in it, and then
you can fill in the right value
for any time period you want.
We can write down a formula
for kt as a function of time.
And that's because
we've learned how
to write energy density
as a function of time,
and we've learned how to
express energy density in terms
of the temperature.
And putting those
two together gives us
a formula for the temperature
as a function of time.
And that formula has the form of
45 h bar cubed c to the fifth,
divided by 16 pi cubed
little g times capital
G, Newton's constant, whole
thing to the 1/4 power, times 1
over the square root of t.
So if we had nothing
but radiation,
and if little g
were constant, this
would be the formula
for the temperature
as a function of time.
Now what actually
happens is that little g
changes as we go through these
different thresholds for which
particles are contributing
to the black-body radiation.
And that means that
the exact formula
is a little bit more
complicated than this.
But as long as you're well
into any one of these periods,
as long as you're not near
any of these border lines,
this formula is in fact a
very accurate approximation
to the temperature as
a function of time.
And an interesting time
period is about one second
after the Big Bang.
And that corresponds to
this g equals 10 and 3/4
that we talked about earlier,
where we have neutrinos
e plus, e minus
pairs, and photons.
And since this is before the
e plus, e minus pairs have
disappeared, the temperature
of the neutrinos at this stage
is still the same as the
temperature of the photon.
So everything is at the
same temperature here.
We just add up the g's.
And the end result for that is
that kt is equal to 0.860 MeV
million electron volts,
divided by the square root of t
in seconds.
There are the units that
you could express it
in in the notes.
Other sets of units are given.
So if 0.86 is about 1, which
it is for many purposes,
then roughly speaking
we're saying at 1 second
after the Big Bang,
kt was about one MeV,
which means it's
higher than the rest
mass of the electrons,
which is 1/2 MeV.
So the electron positron pairs
were still pretty much present
at one second
after the Big Bang,
but they start to disappear
pretty much immediately
after that.
One can also write down what
the temperature itself is.
The temperature is 9.98 times
10 to the ninth k, divided
by the square root
of t in seconds.
OK.
The next item we want
to talk about following
the history of
the early universe
is recombination and decoupling.
Until the temperature
fell to about 4,000
Kelvin, the hydrogen in the
universe, and the universe
was mostly hydrogen, about 20%
helium and the rest hydrogen,
and until the temperature
fell to 4,000 Kelvin,
the hydrogen would be ionized.
This is another
[? stat net ?] calculation
that we're not
going to be doing.
4,000 degrees is not
some magic temperature
associated with hydrogen.
The point at which
the hydrogen ionizers
depends on its density.
But for the densities
in the early universe,
the ionization point
is about 4,000 Kelvin.
So at t equals 4,000 Kelvin
the hydrogen recombines.
Now the word
recombine has somehow
historically taken hold.
So everybody calls
it recombination
in spite of the fact that
according to our theory
it was never combined
previously at any time.
So the prefix re there has
absolutely no meaning whatever,
but nonetheless it is
completely conventional.
OK.
To estimate when
this happens we can
use an important fact,
which we haven't said yet.
Because entropy is conserved
and entropy density
is equal to some
constant times t cubed,
if entropy is conserved
then like mass density
in a matter-dominated universe,
as the universe expands,
the entropy thins out.
And therefore just
like the mass density
in a matter-dominated
universe, the density
should go down like 1 over
a cubed, 1 over the volume.
Now strictly speaking this
is only true if g is fixed.
Well, actually that's not right.
It's always true.
What I'm about to write next
is only true if g is fixed.
If g is fixed then
entropy density
is proportional to
the temperature cubed.
And if you put
these together you
could see that t is
just proportional to 1
over the scale factor.
So as long as little g, as
long as the number of degrees
of freedom contributing to this
black-body radiation is fixed,
the temperature just falls
like 1 over the scale factor.
OK.
So we said that recombination
occurs at 4,000 degrees.
There's actually
another number that's
more interesting,
which is decoupling,
which is slightly colder.
Now the definitions are that
recombination is usually
defined as the temperature
at which half of the hydrogen
has recombined, but some
significant fraction of it
is still not yet recombined.
It doesn't happen suddenly.
It happens gradually.
So you have to pick
some point along the way
to say this is the temperature
that defines the recombination.
Usually take us to
the halfway point,
which I think is the number
used to calculate that.
But perhaps of more
interest is the temperature
at which the photons
decouple in the sense
that as the photons
scatter between then
and now, a typical photon
has not scattered at all.
And that's colder because
when you cross 4,000 K
you still have half of the
hydrogen ionized, which
means there's still
plenty of electrons
around for these photons
to scatter off of.
So you have to cool to
a colder temperature
until the photons cease to
interact with the electron
positrons in any
significant way.
And that's why
decoupling temperature
is somewhat lower than
recombination temperature.
We can estimate at what
time decoupling happened.
Now this is only
a crude estimate,
but will in fact
be pretty accurate.
Since we don't yet even
know about dark energy,
we're going to estimate the
evolution of the universe
between the time of decoupling
and now as being entirely
matter-dominated.
The time of decoupling
is long after the time
of matter radiation equality.
So the universe is
matter dominated
at the time of
decoupling and we're
going to assume it's
matter dominated up
to the present day.
And that means that we know that
the scale factor will evolve
like t to the 2/3, and
therefore the temperature
will evolve, like 1
over t to the 2/3.
And that will be
enough to tell us
how much time is needed
to go from 3,000 Kelvin
to the present
temperature 2.7 Kelvin.
So the time of decoupling
making this approximation
is just the ratio
of the temperatures
t zero over t decoupling,
to the 3/2 power,
times the time today.
[INAUDIBLE] this
fraction in the past.
And plugging in numbers
that's 2.7 over 3,000
to the 3/2 times
13.8 trillion years.
And that's about 380,000 years.
And this in fact
this is pretty much
exactly the number that people
quote when they calculate this
more accurately.
So we really hit it
just about on the nose.
So the time of decoupling
was about 400,000 years
after the Big Bang.
And I should add,
and then we'll stop,
that when we look at the
cosmic background radiation,
what we are really seeing is an
image of the universe at this
time, at the time of decoupling,
because from this time onward
photons have pretty much just
travelled in straight lines.
And that means that when we
look at the cosmic background
radiation we're really seeing
an image of the early universe
in exactly the same way as
you're seeing an image of me
when you observe the photons
there traveling from my face
to your eyes along
straight lines.
It's the same principle.
So this determines
what we're actually
seeing in the cosmic
background radiation.
And therefore it's a very,
very important number.
And we'll stop there now
and continue next time.